hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in section 7 of david hume's inquiry
concerning human understanding
there's a short discussion of a
philosophical doctrine on the nature of
god and the universe that not too many
people buy into
these days that was called back in that
time occasionalism
and it was associated with nicholas
malbrosch
who was in a certain way a cartesian and
trying to grapple with how it is
that events would follow on each other
so there's an explanation of
causality taking place here and
hume is not impressed with this doctrine
and quite frankly
many other people were were not as well
and as we explain it you'll probably
see why because it makes god pretty busy
in in many respects and so
[Music]
he examines it in in the course of
saying well we don't really
understand that well at bottom what's
going on with causality
so he says that
people ordinary people
when they see extraordinary phenomena
they behave in a way that's different
than most philosophers
so ordinary people are perfectly content
to think that
the world is the way it is and causality
works and they understand it
and then there's things like he says
earthquakes
pestilence prodigies of any kind
and now we know how these things happen
earthquakes tectonic shifts right but
there's other things that are mysterious
to us and people do in fact often
assume that there is some sort of
strangeness to certain events and then
there must be something behind that
strangeness so he says that
they find themselves at a loss to assign
a proper cause and to explain the manner
in which the effect is produced by it
they don't understand
how this thing that they're seeing came
to pass
so he says it's usual for men in such
difficulties to have recourse
to some intelligent principle
as the immediate cause of that event
which surprises them
and which they think cannot be accounted
for from the common powers
of nature so you know people back in
hume's time would often attribute these
things to
god or the devil or all sorts of other
things maybe maybe witchcraft if they
were fairly
uneducated at the time although there
were quite a few people
who were still believing in it uh in in
the 18th century
in our own time we have other things
that people will
make appeals to although there are still
people who believe in witches
even to today and most philosophers
he thinks will actually pull up short
and they'll say
okay either we need to say well we don't
really understand this but let's not
attribute it to god
or we'll delve further into the causes
and figure out why these things happen
and you know if you think about natural
philosophers
well they they did that with diseases
and and you know eventually we figure
out what causes cholera
what causes all these other sorts of
things and we find remedies for them or
earthquakes
or pick whatever else you you want
some philosophers however he says
think themselves obliged by reason
so the thing that's really you know key
for a philosopher using reason
to have recourse on all occasions
not just on some occasions on all
occasions
to the same principle which the vulgar
never appeal to but in cases that appear
miraculous and supernatural so
they're treating everything as if it's
miraculous and supernatural
and he he goes on and he summarizes what
they say they acknowledge
mind and intelligence to be not only the
ultimate and original cause of all
things
so that god would have you know maybe
made everything originally and set it up
and then it kind of goes along in its
own way
but instead the immediate and soul cause
of
every event which appears in nature
so this is occasionalism and in the next
sentence hume
tells us that they pretend that these
objects which are commonly
denominated causes are in reality
nothing but occasions what do we mean by
occasions there well so
they're just the you know creation of a
possibility for something happening or
they're
they're creating the time for god to
actually get the call
and is a very very busy god in this
scheme
and and make the the link happen so
you know for example if i drop this book
if i choose to drop this book right now
which i'm not going to do because i need
to read from it
then god makes it's not gravity making
anything happen it's god
making the book fall and i observe both
things i observe my letting the book go
and i observe the book falling
and i attribute it to gravity but it's
really god operating behind the scenes
and
same for any other causal relation
they're merely
occasions and so he says the true and
direct principle of
every effect every single effect is not
only power
or force in nature but a volition
of the supreme being who wills that such
particular objects should forever be
conjoined with each other
so if you think this out for just a
second what would that sort of god be
and what would his or her its life be
like
it is tapped into everything throughout
the universe
including what's going on in our minds
and every time that there's something
that we ourselves take to be cause and
effect
that that deity that supreme being
supreme mind
makes it happen we are merely
occasioning things but
the real story is that god is incredibly
active
behind the scenes and so it's god's
volition
and occasions that work together and he
he talks about
how this would work for external objects
how this would work for the mind-body
interaction
and the mind's internal operation so
we'll run through this fairly quickly he
says that
instead of saying one billiard ball
moves another by a force which it's
derived from the author of nature
it's the deity himself they say who by a
particular volition
moves the second ball being determined
to this operation by the impulse of the
first ball
in consequence of those general laws
which he has laid down to himself
in the government of the universe so god
sort of made a script for himself
and he follows that script in every
single little thing
if we go on a little bit further the
mind and the body right he says
we philosophers advancing still on their
inquiries
discoverers were totally ignorant to the
power on which depends the mutual
operation of bodies were no less
ignorant of that power
on which depends the operation of mind
on body or of body on mind
nor are we able either from our senses
or consciousness to assign the ultimate
principle in the one case
more than the other so
these occasionalists assert that the
deity is the immediate cause of the
union between soul and body
and that they're not the organs of sense
which being agitated by external objects
produce sensations of the mind
but its particular volition of our
omnipotent maker which excites such a
sensation
in consequence of such a motion in the
organ so
you know it's one way of solving the
problem of consciousness isn't it or at
least the problem of perception
how is it my eye is perceiving that
light over there well you know there's
some things happening and then god's
volition makes it all come together
you start to see where this is going
don't you
what about the mind's internal
operations
he says that they extend the same
inference to the mind itself
our mental vision or conception of ideas
is nothing but a
revelation made to us by our own maker
when we voluntarily turn our thoughts to
any object and raise up its image in the
fancy and imagination
it's not the will which creates that
idea it's the universal creator who
discovers it to the mind and renders it
present to us so we're all carrying
around this stock of ideas
and whenever we call one of them up god
is the projectionist behind the scene
who you know starts starts up the
projector and boom there it is for us or
whatever one whatever sort of metaphor
we want for this to
imagine it hume says that this is
not a very good way to look at things as
a matter of fact
he he criticizes it and he might say
well why is he criticizing it who
actually
buys into this well there were quite a
few people at the time who
who did and i suppose you could actually
extend this
to you know the idea of a cartesian
demon
or you know living in a simulation or
anything like that if you wanted to
except that usually we talk about there
being glitches in that right
so hume says that there's a big problem
with this one of the big problems
is that he says they don't consider that
by this theory they diminish instead of
magnifying the grandeur of those
attributes which they affect so much to
celebrate what are those
attributes the divine power the divine
wisdom all of these things that we
attribute to god
and if we're saying that god is like
this this
poor guy behind the scenes constantly
you know
reacting to everything that we're doing
there's something kind of screwy about
that but there's also another
issue that he brings up here hume says
it argues more power in the deity to
delegate a certain degree of power to
inferior creatures
than to produce everything by his own
immediate volition
doesn't it make more sense that god
would
give the billiard ball the ability to
hit another billiard ball and take care
of its own business you know
or god would create complex creatures
like us
with minds capable of calling up ideas
without god
having to be directly involved in it so
you know that's that's uh hume's
assertion there he also talks about
wisdom
takes more wisdom to set up a world that
can kind of work on its own
then he talks about two philosophical
reflections that would also
help to refute this one of them is very
typically human
he says that um
though the chain of arguments which are
being used for this doctrine were ever
so logical there must arise a strong
suspicion
if not an absolute assurance that it has
carried us quite beyond the reach of our
faculties so our abilities our natural
capacities
intellect reason will all those sorts of
things that we have even imagination
it's carried us quite beyond the reach
of our faculties
when it leads to conclusions so
extraordinary and so remote from common
life and experience if we
if we have to leave behind common life
and experience
we're starting to get into what he calls
fairy land
we're starting to get into the realm of
almost pure imagination
and if we're going to imagine a god
behind the scenes we could imagine all
sorts of other things and
you do in fact see hume having his
characters talk about things like this
and the dialogues on natural
religion so he says we've got into fairy
land
long before we've reached the last steps
of our theory and there we have no
reason to trust our common
methods of argumentation or to think our
usual analogies and probability
have any authority once once we start
opening the door to this hume says
we can really just imagine anything and
we've got no way of deciding between
them we can't count probabilities
the other thing that he points out is he
says
we're ignorant of the manner in which
bodies operate on each other we don't
understand force or
energy are we not equally ignorant of
the manner or force by which a mind even
the supreme mind operates either on
itself or on body
where do we acquire any idea of it we
have no sentiment or consciousness of
this power in ourselves we have no idea
of the supreme being
but what we learn from reflection on our
own faculty so if we're kind of a
mystery to ourselves already
when it comes to our own workings and is
what we have
more experience with you know intimate
experience
how in the hell are we going to know
anything about the divine
mind that we could assert with any sort
of
real certainty or even probability we
humans saying we can't so
these occasionalists they have an
interesting story
about how causality works it's not even
really causality or
if there is quasi-alia it's the divine
volition all the time
but there's really no reason why we
should accept this according to hume
you